et en allemagne les personnes hostiles
aux mesures anti-copie dons bravé
l'interdiction de manifester aujourd'hui
ils étaient dans les rues de berlin par
centaines à la police anti-émeute a été
déployée et des affrontements ont eu
lieu les manifestants ont dénoncé les
restrictions sanitaires imposées par les
autorités dont l'éventualité de
conditionner l'accès à certains lieux
certains lieux est la vaccination une
mobilisation sur appel du mouvement
quaden coeur qui signifie libre penseur
et gilbert casasus professeur d'études
européennes est revenue sur les dessous
de ce mouvement en allemagne et que tu
es alors aujourd'hui il ya eu 3 environ
mille manifestants à berlin se souvenir
que berlin cogan millions d'habitants
donc c'est relativement peu important il
ya quelques mois il y avait eu plus d'un
manifestant ce mouvement ne semble pas
prendre de l'ampleur nous sommes à moins
de deux mois des élections allemandes et
je ne pense pas que ce mouvement dans le
cadre de la politique allemande de la
politique intérieure de la campagne
électorale puisse véritablement joué un
grand rôle
d'autant que beaucoup d'allemands
n'apprécie pas beaucoup ce mouvement et
quand on parle de créatine cas c'est à
dire ce qu'ils pensent pas comme il faut
ou à travers si vous voulez on sait que
ces gens là sont extrêmement
minoritaires et qui dira pas du tout est
là aussi il faut savoir que le parti de
l'extrême droite l'afd en sous main
soutient ce mouvement